[Música]
l
ah
[Música]
tuve una infancia dura
pero
trate de disfrutarla como pude
y con lo que tenía
mi casa
era una habitación
al fondo del patio de la casa de mi
abuela
hay vivíamos
con mis hermanos y mis padres
mi papá tsangari
mi mamá en ese momento ama de casa
luego cuando ya crecimos un poco
mi mamá puedo salir a buscar un trabajo
y esto nos posibilitó poder
alquilar una casa más a la periferia de
la ciudad
donde los alquileres son un poco más
baratos
en este barrio
aprendí muchas cosas
donde la vida básicamente me enseñó los
golpes
a mis 13 años
solía esperar a mi mamá
en una garita de colectivo
donde ella bajaba
porque volvió tarde de su trabajo
una noche de invierno
hacía frío
me detienen
la policía
me realizan
y cuando digo de dónde soy lo llevan
me golpean
y me hacen preguntas en la comisaría
me dejan marcas en el cuerpo
y con mi mamá hicimos una denuncia
y me llamaron porque resulte esos pechos
por mi ropa
por mi gorra
cuando hacemos la denuncia con mi mamá
sólo conseguimos
agravar la situación
porque esas detenciones nunca se
detuvieron
porque habíamos denunciado a unos
policías
al mismo tiempo
estaba haciendo el secundario
mi primer año
y la verdad que a veces
se me hacía muy complicado por estar
muchas horas sentado en una silla
con la panza vacía
muchas veces
me descompuse dentro del aula por nueve
el comido
y también cuando llegaba a mi casa
muchas veces
la mesa vacía
solía llegar
y sabía ver a mi papá durmiendo en una
silla
con una caja de vino al lado
atravesado por un consumo de alcohol
que lo dominaba totalmente
mi mamá que llegaba
las discusiones que empezaban
y que muchas veces
terminaban en violencia
un día
decidí no ir más al colegio
y salir a hacer charlas con mi papá
aunque no me pagase
sabía que esa plata iba para mi casa
con mis amigos
cuando lo contábamos
había algo que siempre estaba presente
era la droga
nos faltaba
en este barrio
estaba en cada paso
en todas las esquinas
un día probé
y este consumo empezó a crecer más en mí
ya no lo dominaba
a veces le sacaba plata a mi mamá a
escondidas
iba y consumía
muchas veces me robaba algo
y va consumía
el consumo
se había apropiado de mí
cuando salíamos
para el centro
con mis amigos
nunca podríamos llegar al destino que
queríamos llegar
porque por ser de un barrio que estaba
estigmatizado
no deberíamos caminar por el centro
tenemos que estar en el barrio
a mis 14 años
en la parte de una banda de un grupo de
amigos
empecé a manejar un arma también
mi vida estaba totalmente perdida
pero solamente esperar la muerte
a mis 15 años recibo el primer disparo
en mi cuerpo
por parte de otra banda de otro barrio
y en el año 2008 a mis 18 años
soy acusado de un robo
me llevan a la cárcel
y algo que me llamó la atención en ese
momento
fue que era el más chico del pabellón
porque tenía 18 años
y los demás tenían de 30 a 35 para
arriba
estuve 11 meses en un pabellón de
procesado donde solamente vi dos veces
a mi abogado defensor
la primera vez que lo vi a los días de
mi detención
solamente me dijo hacete cargo
a los 11 meses en la primera audiencia
de juicio
de nuevo me dijo act card
recibo mi condena
de 10 años de los cuales tenía que hacer
6 años y 8 meses
con la condicional que es un beneficio
que se da por única vez a aquellos que
tengan conductas
y fases que se le llaman dentro de la
cárcel que es un período en donde van
evaluando
en donde hay un psicólogo un trabajador
social
para 500 600 personas
y ellos te ven una vez cada seis meses
mis primeros años
la pasaba en la cama
consumiendo
muchas veces
en el calabozo
el lugar donde
[Música]
solamente tienen 23 horas y media por
día encerrado y solamente sale un ratito
de limpio del celda
después de varias existencias por parte
de las profesoras que trabajaban dentro
de ese lugar en el área educativa
un día
me decidió salir del colegio
al principio o 6 y salí para estudiar
pero quería salir un rato del pabellón
y lo que sea en ti en el aula cuando
entraba
lo que nos hacían sentir las profesoras
era que estábamos
en un colegio
en los momentos de libertad
un día
en un trabajo que nos hace hacer una
profesora
había que escribir algo que nos
recordara el barrio
y yo escribo algo
ella se lleva ese trabajo y cuando
vuelve con el trabajo
me había escrito una devolución
y sentí que por primera vez
había hecho algo que alguien le había
gustado
esa simple de evolución
me hizo sentir que estaba vivo
porque hasta ese momento no me sentía
vivo
esta profe
insiste escribir y me regala
un libro
mi primer libro
el libro
lleva como título
la venganza del cordero atado
que fue escrito por un pibe que también
estuvo preso en buenos aires
pero cuando ella me da este libro
para mí era raro tener un libro en la
mano
ese contacto
con ese libro
fue todo un descubrimiento para mí
nunca había tenido uno en la mano nunca
había leído un libro
y lo que conocía
del arte y lo que pensaba hasta ese
momento era que el arte era solo para
una clase social y no para otros
no leo el libro cuando ella me lo da
lo que hago
es dejarlo arriba de una mesa de luz que
tenía en la celda
porque yo decía
pero si me voy a poner un leer un libro
cada dentro
para qué
pasan unos días
estaba sentado en una cama en la cama de
mi celda
y se me da por abrir el libro
cuando abro el libro
me encuentro con una frase
y esta frase decía
es más peligroso un pibe que piensa
que uno que roba
y su decía
como puede ser que sea peligroso un pibe
que piense
que era de peligroso pensar
en ese contexto
esa frase me llevó a leer todo el libro
le vi muchas veces
no podía parar de leerlo
había descubierto algo
y no sólo leí ese libro sino también
empecé a leer lo que pasaba alrededor
mío
y hacerme preguntas
porque él michelle de éramos siete
y cuatro éramos del mismo barrio
porque en el pabellón
había 90
y 40 eran del mismo barrio
yo creía que eso no era una casualidad
algo pasaba
en el colegio
participe de todos los talleres que pude
terminé el secundario
regrese hoy
y al mismo tiempo
combatía con esta dirección que me
atravesaba una adicción que fue durante
diez años
cuando cuando mi cuerpo
podía consumir
cuando mi ansiedad
intentaba
vencerme
yo ya tenía preparado
un ejército de palabras para enfrentarla
y a eso lo escribía en una hoja
nos empezamos a organizar dentro del
pabellón
porque la violencia siempre estaba
presente
entonces lo que hacíamos cuando un pibe
tenía que reclamar algo pero juntarnos
en la celda y hacer un escrito y
presentarlo
porque el que no conoce sus derechos o
no sabe lo que es un código penal
lo que hace es hacerse cortes en el
cuerpo
para reclamar no es porque están locos
quisimos romper esa estructura de ese
sistema
que nos empujaba
y que los quería endurecer nuestro
corazón
pintar el pabellón hacen murales
escribir frases
y siempre me mandaban a hablar a mí
con el director
en ese lugar tenía un amigo emiliano que
fuimos amigos del barrio y nos
encontramos ahí
con él fue el primero que empecé a
compartir mis poemas
porque dentro de la cárcel escribir un
poder o como ser débil en un lugar de
estar repleto de hombres
cuando escribió lo compartió con él
y en un día entró con un cuaderno a mi
celda y también había escrito un poema
y ahí empezamos a compartiendo
un día a la madrugada me sacan
del pabellón
y me llevan a varias cárceles dentro de
la provincia de córdoba también de san
francisco
y nadie me decía porque me llevaba
cuando llega la resolución del director
porque el director tenía que decir
porque me sacaba del establecimiento
en la resolución en su descargo decía
que era peligroso para segundos y para
terceros
y en ese momento
me di cuenta porque pensar podría ser
peligroso
cuando salgo en el 2015 y digo cuando
salgo porque no me gusta así recuperé mi
libertad
porque yo encontré la llave de mi
libertad y encontré la libertad cuando
estaba ya adentro
cuando comencé a pensar en ese momento
fue libre
después me abrió el portón y me fui
pero volver a empezar
permita que la suerte de que tenía mis
hermanos a mi familia que me acompañaban
y los profesores que me acompañaron
también en ese proceso
nos empezamos a organizar
y cuando salió de la cárcel me fui con
una con una visión
así como en aquel momento fui el más
chico del pabellón por mi edad
cuando salí de 2015 los pabellones están
llenos de pibes de entre 18 o 20 años
la mayor población no tiene secundario
la mayor población no conoce sus
derechos
hace poco presenté mi primer libro la
falla del sistema la poesía mi libertad
en este libro también están los poemas
de emiliano
miren los aviones 2012 en el 2014 fue
asesinado en la puerta de su casa
pero sus poemas también están acá
en un trabajo que hicimos colectivo en
el barrio
entonces yo me pregunto
y también les les pregunto
para quienes son realmente las parcelas
le conviene el sistema que los pibes
empiezan a pensar
o también los ignorantes
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y